[Musique]
maintenant que tu vis à l'autre bout de
Paris quand tu veux changer
d'âge tu t'offres un long voyage tu
viens me dire bonjour au coin de la rue
du Four tu viens me visiter à
Saint-Germain des prês il n'y a plus
d'après à Saint-Germain des
prês plus d'après-demain plus
d'après-midi il n'y a qu'aujourd'hui
quand je te
reverrai à Saint-Germain des
pra ce ne sera plus toi ce ne sera plus
moi il n'y a plus d'autre fois tu me dis
comme tout change les rutes semblent
étranges même les cafés crème non plus
le goût que tu aimes c'est que tu es une
autre c'est que je suis un autre nous
sommes étrangers à SaintGermain des prê
il n'y a plus
d'après à Saint-Germain des
prês plus d'après-demain plus
d'après-midi il n'y a qu'aujourd'hui
quand je te
reverrai à Saint-Germain des
vra ce ne sera plus toi ce ne sera plus
moi il n'y a plus d'autre foi à vivre au
jour le jour le moindre des amours
prenait dans ses ruelles des allures
éternelles mais à la nuit la nuit
c'était bientôt
fini voici
l'éternité de SaintGermain des PR a plus
d'après à Saint-Germain des
prê plus d'après-demain plus
d'après-midi il n'y a qu'aujourd'hui
quand je te
reverrai à Saint-Germain des
prê ce ne sera plus toi ce ne sera plus
moi il n'y a plus d'autre
[Musique]
fois